فهد يداعبك اليفا تصرف غير مالوف من حيوان
مفترس كهذا ذلك الحيوان المتوحش الذي فطر
على افتراس الحيوانات الاضعف منه يصبح
صديقا لطيفا لحيوان اخر تصرف كسر به جميع
قوانين الغاب التي ياكل فيها القوي الطيف
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
الصداقه سلوك اجتماعي اختص به البشر دونا
عن غيرهم من الكائنات تجسد مشاعر الحب
والالفه والاهتمام فيما بينهم لكن ان نرى
تلك المشاعر بين حيوانات من اجناس مختلفه
فهذا امر نادر الحدوث خصوصا عندما يكون
احد طرفيها حيوانا مفترسا كهذا المشهد
مثلا
ثعلب يظهر وهو ينادي صديقا له بحماس على
ما يبدو ليظهر ذلك الصديق انه حيوان غرير
العسل حيونان مفترسان انطوائيا او هذا ما
نعرفه عنهما على الاقل لكن هذه المشاهد
كسرت القاعده تماما
بحسب العلماء فان انواعا كثيره من
الحيوانات في الحياه البريه تشكل صداقات
بين ابناء جنسها شبيهه بالصداقات بين
البشر كحيوانات الشمبانزي مثلا وانواع من
الطيور والاسماك والخيول والدلافين وتعتمد
في التعبير عن صداقتها باللمس تماما
كالمصافحه والعناق لدى البشر
[موسيقى]
ياتي التي تنخرط فيها الحيوانات لتكوين
الصداقات والحفاظ عليها عمليه تماما
الغربان تهيئ الاصدقاء بلطف بمناقرها
بينما تقوم القرود بتهيئه الاصدقاء
بايديها لا تختلف هذه السلوكيات كثيرا عن
كيفيه احتضان البشر لاصدقائهم
لكن السؤال هنا هل تشكل الحيوانات صداقات
مع انواع اخرى الكثير من المشاهد في
الحياه البريه تم رصدها للصداقات غير
متوقعه بين حيوانات اليفه ومفترسه فهنا دب
بني متوحش يداعب كلب هاسكي وهذا شمبانزي
يمرح مع اسد صغير وهنا قط يرافق صديقه
الكلب المصاب
العلماء لاحظوا ان نسبه كبيره من الصداقات
بين الحيوانات الاليفه والمتوحشه تكونت في
حالات تربى فيها الحيوانات في مكان واحد
او كان الحيوان المتوحش مروضا غير انهم لم
يستبعدوا فرضيه تكوينها لصداقات خارج
طبيعتها وغريزتها
[موسيقى]
يعني
سلوك الحيوانات الخاص بالصداقه يعتبر من
اكثر السلوكيات غرابه لكن ابحاثا عده خلصت
ان هناك اسبابا تدفع بالحيوانات لتشكيل
تلك الصداقات منها الحصول على الحمايه
والامان وتوفير الطعام والمحافظه على
النسل